[Music]
[Music]
in the simulation today we're sitting
down with the day rusty hey what's up
thanks for coming on the show my
pleasure this is the second time you
were first guest that was special a lot
of backlight a lot of backlight face in
the Bay Bridge that was good that was
our first daily show and now we're at
number 66 a day oh wow
come a long way we came a long way
decently quickly
- what's your favorite episode I don't
know now that you're here I'm just
thinking back about how society is a
bunch of five-year-olds I just can't
forget about that I've been learning a
lot about from a lot of different people
across a lot of different industries and
it's been very enriching to have the
have the opportunity to be a listener
and an interlocutor for for other people
and hopefully to inspire other people
that are watching to be like holy cow
there's so many cool things happening
across all these different industries
how do we get involved how do we learn
how do we inspire kids to care about
these things so that's kind of what we
can do with this hopefully so I
certainly last time I was on you know I
was rushing around also rushing around
today but I would distinctly remember
just having a thousand things and I'm
like what's this about and we were
talking so I was pretty pretty to the
point about a number of different
questions that you asked and now today
I'm fasting so I'm not gonna I'm not
going to say that it's any less to the
point but hopefully I'll have a milder
edge to my responses to the line of
discussion that we go down
I do have you given the idea of the
overall awareness of society you give
that a lot of thought in your in your
day-to-day like you're looking around
you're always observing analyzing the
way that we're doing things that's
seeing how they can be better yes and
and on the whole it's generally a low
level of consciousness you know one of
the things I like about fasting is talk
about a way to artificially wake
yourself up you know day five to day
seven of a fast you are going to be very
awake you know admittedly you might be
focused on food right so but all your
senses are optimally working you can
smell things very far away you can hear
things very far away assuming that you
can control your urges for food you know
that's about one of the most awake
states that you can be in as a human
being
unfortunately you know if you're eating
lots of food lots of processed food
you're not sleeping well you're
basically not challenging your mind and
you're not exercising that's the inverse
state of fasting and you're basically
physically asleep regardless of whether
your mind is awake so you know I think
most people have a physical state of
asleep Ness coupled with a mental state
of asleep Ness and and that's something
I'm working on you mentioned this this
challenging this these
called these norms that are baked into
us which is this eating three times a
day eating whatever some times that we
see not even questioning where it came
from these kind of things when you when
you do have the the pleasure to go on a
fast for a little period of time it
almost takes us back to the feeling of
not knowing exactly when that next meal
was exactly coming and it triggers a lot
of different things you know when you
know when you're about to put that bite
of food into your mouth after a couple
days of fasting you salivate so much
when you're first chewing so you you
actually appreciate your food again well
especially if it's good food I mean that
the one of the issues that we have today
that has been consuming me if you will
is how poor our food infrastructure is I
mean the the reality is if you take a
bunch of people are not conscious and
you ask them to build the world this is
about the best world you're gonna get
and it's it's really out of whack right
because again people aren't fully
conscious so you know we're feeding
ourselves the food is just terrible so
yeah it's true that you solving and
you're very eager to eat whatever it is
but you know there's a huge difference
if it's a Dorito or if it's you know a
freshly picked orange or something like
that and and the reality is for most
people it's going to be a Dorito right
so there's a lot of that I mean it you
one of the things that you I grapple
with being awake and conscious is where
do you start
right so for example since I was last on
the show which I guess would have been
towards the end of last year right and
you know early this year early this year
was it early this year
Wow the reason I say wow is because
since then you know I've done a number
of things so I started a think tank
and we're actually doing an event this
weekend on consumption and what's it
called one it's called one yes and it
can we is it public when we publicly
address the location or is this no I I'm
not I mean if someone's eager to go it's
about consumption it involves a hike
there you can also camp if you're
interested you can just hit me on
Twitter I guess or but but the it's not
it's not you know I'm debating whether
to make it public or not you know what I
don't want to do is have turned into a
party well it's it's it's a intentional
community yeah so and and we have themes
for each of the different things that we
do and it's been very informative on a
number of different things including the
fact that most of our mental models for
how the world operated wrong so that
that's been interesting since and and
you know we've done a number of events
since being on the show last which
wasn't all that long ago so I'm like wow
this is the third one this is a camping
and hiking in one we did another one on
a ranch and then we did the first one in
a secret garage month ish it's been
about that right so the first one was
really thinking about well-being the
second one was that the topic was unplug
and it was a bit basically about the
collapse of social media and how social
media is really damaging humanity and
then this one is about consumption just
looking at the sheer amount of waste
that we produce living our daily lives
which is excessive and and you know the
idea is that you want to take out of
this inspiration but also action and
what I've learned through it is that
there is a certain there the what I'll
call super connectors okay so humanity
as best as I can tell it seems to have
and somewhat unconscious substrata to it
and it's you know there there's evidence
of this substrata existing in other
animals ergo you have alpha males and
things like that but you know who is an
alpha male isn't always explicit by
who's the largest well there's some sort
of inherent communication layer that's
going on between animals so I think
there is what I call super nodes and
these are individuals around which ideas
and theories radiate and what's
interesting is if you Brent you can
bring super nodes together and agree on
things and have a profound impact I mean
in many ways you can argue this is the
genesis of things like the g8 or Davos
or something like that try and get as
many super nodes together and talk about
things you know unfortunately a lot of
times they get together and they talk
about like how do I make more money for
myself right because I don't think much
of the world including the super nodes
are incredibly enlightened at this
moment but what I'm trying to do is
bring an intentional community together
that includes super nodes for the
purpose of radiating out important
changes in society yes
I'm glad that you started that I think
you're really you're probably the right
person for that in this Bay Area
community I think you are we'll see you
know it's it's has its challenges let's
put it that way it's not the you know
every
so Taipei here that it's very hard to to
wrangle scheduling it's fascinating but
to some extent it doesn't really matter
cuz what I've also found is like the
right people will be there for what it
is right and in many ways it's not even
you don't need it's not a volume thing
it's not like all we had a 5,000 person
event with quality
what's this suit which goes back to you
know no it's super connectors right and
the idea of opening it up or not you
know I'm not so I'll give you an example
of you know cause of fact and and what
is what but so we had one called unplug
as I was telling you about and we really
looked at the negative consequences of
the the constant mobile connection
social media it's all just fake metrics
of popularity like how many people like
me like really like how many people
hearted my photo like and which was fake
to begin with so you know and and this
is like you know our children yes are
being taught that these vanity metrics
are important and that to me is a
dangerous road to tread because I don't
personally see how you could look at
that in a constructive way in the long
term right oh the vanity metrics of
likes is going to somehow elevate human
consciousness and make us better no but
if we were to make the case for it with
the with using it to propel a very
conscious message across the social
fabric well so I I don't there that then
you get back to the medium
message right and and there's a lot of
theory about you know our how
interrelated are the two and how
effective are would a you know one type
of message be on a different kind of
medium right so when you look at and and
there was a very easy example with
President Trump who on Twitter with his
you know hundred forty character
missives can generate millions and
millions of followers and and fans
recently Kanye West has been doing this
and and then if you flip over but and
put him on you know broadcast television
as a president he just he looks more
like a reality TV star he doesn't fit
the role very well in that medium so the
medium and the message are are from live
to four hundred forty characters is a
big difference versus in person in front
of a big audience could write suit so
back to your question can you use that
medium so it seems to me that right now
social media is effective at vanity
metrics and essentially hate speech and
and hate speech is a strong word but let
me put it another way if I say something
perfectly nice and plain vanila like you
look great today no one cares if I'm
like if I say something with an edge
that is somewhat like controversial like
that shirt makes you look like inserted
slang word I promise the following
statement is a thousand percent true
it's zero likes vanity metrics versus
you ignite the inner
that yeah right so if the if the medium
is designed for vanity metrics the
message is going through the medium are
gonna be highly correlated and right now
the vanity metrics are pulling out
really kind of hate speech racial
divides and other things that I don't
think are positive to humanity so I
don't know if you could take a positive
message for Humanity and and and push
his medium through this medium I don't
think so you know I have no impure tell
me one sure there seems to be a couple
people that are pushing good messaging
for example well I've just used myself
as an example that I sure that I
messaged out and I got a decent amount
of Attraction on this message work okay
world is a complex place so I spend as
much of my time possible learning and
stuff like that
at least he says yeah a little scratch
in the head yeah so I'll give you a
slightly better one Elan right Elon Musk
but you know with that said like he
trolls the internet deliberately he
makes bad joke you made a flame core for
heaven sakes right true so he you know
here's a guy who probably does have a
good heart and all this stuff and and
then you know trolls the Internet at the
same time and you know making a
flamethrower and I wrote hat salesman on
his like bio on Twitter yeah so I mean
you know the medium and the message are
highly related and and it's an
interesting time right now so let's take
a step back because I know we're talking
about simulation stuff like this well
our simulation is about to break okay
cuz let me let me let me help you with
like where things are let me help you
with your with your one community so
that way we don't break the simulation
well so so jobs are going away
I was somewhere being born as well some
new jobs are coming well well we can
talk we can talk about what those new
jobs are but jobs are going they're
highly skilled jobs in many ways yeah
jobs as we know them are going away the
world of command and control you get
paid to do something
so almost all manual labor from field
work to factories are gonna be replaced
by robots of robots now are very
advanced almost all white-collar work
and I was talking with one of the top AI
guys in the world yesterday in my office
and there is really nothing and it's not
even AI because under AI you have this
deep learning machine learning with the
quema the present-day capabilities of
machine learning and deep learning alpha
zero is pretty scary now
so we'll forget about AI where I forget
about like AI coming in but just the
basics of like taking a data set and and
an understanding or taking a photo and
determining like disease or illness or
something like that that you know
everything from doctors lawyers the cat
bankers the entire sort of white-collar
professional field is is is is a is a
couple dev cycles away from being
obviated out of existence now so you've
got your white-collar jobs going away
your blue-collar god jobs going away and
then you know what's money right you
can't work to make money so then how do
you get money right and what do you use
money for you know while all this is
happening I don't know if you notice but
you know everything has become
ridiculously inexpensive like yes your
cell phones
expensive because apples sitting on
billions of dollars of your money but if
a cop
they give things away for free these
glasses were six dollars right you know
that that's I mean at this point that
the cost of stuff is coming way down and
you don't need to work so where is
everything going now I'll tell you if we
don't consciously start thinking about
it it's gonna drive off a cliff yeah
because you can't put the massive
humanity out of work without some sort
of plan correct
right so you know one of the things that
I'm hopeful about and I think is a
beautiful thing is people today as I
mentioned this command and control world
is falling apart around us you don't
work for anyone anymore you're not gonna
be working in a factory you're not gonna
be working in the Starbucks you're not
gonna be working in a field you're not
gonna be an accountant you're not gonna
be a doctor you're not gonna be a lawyer
most of those things are gonna be gone
ten years for sure twenty years
definitely so you know between 10 and 20
years from now you know the way we live
will be radically different yeah now you
can create things that inspire people to
work with you on problems to make to fix
the world to make the world better so I
think that's the model of the future
where we're headed where instead of you
getting a job doing something for
someone you say look here is a major
problem in the world that I need now I
believe needs to be fixed or I I feel is
my purpose to work on if you can
eloquently state that to the world
you'll find other people who
are those same beliefs in worldview and
you'll work with them to make the world
better
yeah now that might not be a job in the
classic sense you may not be happy you
know you may not have a role you may not
have a task list that you do every day
it certainly won't be repetitive work
right I mean we can thankfully kiss
goodbye the era of repetitive work I
mean that's gone so you'll be doing a
lot more mind related work as you were
saying
but then again what is compensation in
that world right how do you get paid who
pays for what now I believe that success
is belief or belief is the new currency
of success and let me explain that so
it's it's a interesting concept when you
don't have money don't really have a job
what is how do you get resources what is
success and I think the more that people
believe in the vision that you're
working on the more successful that
vision will be in the world the more
resources you're going to get to work on
it and eventually that will translate
into you know achieving that vision
which is the ultimate metric of success
so crypto is a great example of that
crypto has no value if a Bitcoin has no
value the more people that believe in
Bitcoin the more valuable it becomes
and then you can use it for things in
theory and what's going to happen is
that's how society is going to start to
work going forward you create something
that people believe in the sort of
value of the world gets aggregated by
the group that's working on it and you
know they become therefore successful in
achieving their mission so really if you
look at belief and this is kind of a
profound thing that I'm grappling with
myself and I'm sure a lot of people are
in this transitional time is you know
where does it start and where does it
end right so I think it starts with
believing in yourself first right which
is hard because most people are asleep
not necessarily trying and probably
don't believe in a lot of things that
they see outside of themselves we need a
social fabric that helps people find
within themselves what they love and do
that thing right well and then maybe
they should believe in exactly what you
just said some sort of vision of the
world but I don't think you can believe
in a vision of the world if you don't
believe in yourself right you believe in
yourself first then you believe in the
vision of the world but then you got to
get people to believe with you in that
vision right yes fan and also your
biggest critic at the same time well
hopefully right hopefully they're not
just yes people they are I mean they're
on their own journey with value to add
right that's why I'm not I'm very
careful about not saying for you but
with you safe you they believe with you
in the visions and they work with you on
the vision and then after you get
initial quote-unquote team members maybe
you get investors maybe you get users
customers and you can spread this these
wings of belief wide and and create
something amazing and I think that is
probably the best use of someone's
energy right now
is to kind of slap themselves out of a
slumber and it's gonna have in one of
two ways
okay either they're gonna get fired from
their job kicked out of their house and
have them in their family on the street
in some number of years from now that's
less than 20 and probably over ten or
they're gonna start consciously taking
control of their life now
yeah and addressing these things and
it's very dangerous the first one is the
one that happens well it's headed that
way how many how many truckers are
thinking of their trier right exactly
are thinking their post trucking career
it's the number one middle class
employer in the country of America and
the United States million a total of
four yeah for millions including taxi
and truck right no no four million just
truck yeah so imagine like that's a so
that's double that's a big chunk of the
population right there that's huge right
and so it's over ten percent and they're
all middle-class you know maybe some on
the fringe or not but it's a
middle-class job it's considered the the
the middle of the middle-class world and
it's they're going away and I don't
think they have a lot of retraining
going on so so someone needs to be
working this problem right and it
doesn't seem like the people themselves
but I in the best-case scenario you have
people themselves saying like okay I'm
not like I don't I see the writing on
the wall a little bit right you don't
need to be fully conscious I need to do
right that that's step one hopefully or
secondly you know people like me can
also go out there and try and work with
as many people as possible maybe an
actual autonomous truck needs to show up
in those actual truck stops and they
need to see the autonomous truck driving
cargo loads yeah but nobody I mean maybe
that's what has to happen oh that is
happening but but I mean maybe in order
for them to finally kick it into into
gear so I'm just wondering one of the
mechanism know that kick people into
gear sadly kick is the operative word I
mean no one just like rolls out about a
gear right you often get hit really hard
right so last time I was on the show not
that long ago you know I had just exited
a period where I had been hit really
hard it just happens right you get
situations that come up in life where by
either external forces or internal
forces or something in between you get
knocked down right and a lot of times
and you get knocked down you you you're
awake yeah right
so unfortunately like just I and I have
an anecdotal evidence that your point
about the seeing the truck won't work
because I used to believe that similar
thesis that you could show someone
something sufficiently amazing that they
would have no choice but to wake up
whatever insert blank Wow and so that
was the genesis of my involvement in
space in the XPrize because I figured
that oh I could do I could effectuate
something at such a grand scale that
when they when Humanity actually saw
that was just a bunch of
ragtag people it would inspire them that
they could do anything and in fact you
know that didn't work so we and it's
it's super not didn't work so XPrize
itself did the impossible we with a
small team of people created a system
that caused Humanity for the first time
in history to send people to space
privately okay and I can tell you that
the entire board of directors when I
joined it might have been five or six
people and that was the entire
organization
maybe they had a someone in an office
somewhere that was doing some accounting
or something but that was basically and
they had an executive director who was
part-time so it was like us very small
and then you know a few years later
people went to space privately but that
and it got a lot of media but it didn't
change anything and then you know you
have someone like you on Musk who came
out of that initiative and is taking us
to Mars and he's become a bit of a cult
legend but rather than people saying hey
this guy did it I can do it they're just
like wow he lawns amazing right and it's
not like oh well maybe you're amazing
too it's like nah he's amazing it's like
oh okay so you know I don't think again
like the truck coming up in the thing
they see it while it's amazing like how
does it affect me does it mean that I'm
they're gonna in affected when the
eviction notice comes on their door as
their loved one has cancer because they
haven't been eating well and then
they're like I'm off path this is broken
and unfortunately that type of rude
awakening often doesn't wind up with
someone running out and hugging a
neighbor right it usually winds up with
someone grabbing their shotgun and
blowing away people at the local food
store so you know that that my concern
is like we have enough top that that the
window closes every day it's closed
right we see the the landing strip over
there we the pilot just had a heart
attack and there's plenty of time to
like figure out how to fly the plane
right now yeah right
but if we don't actually take control of
the plane right now we are going to
crash and that crash will not be pretty
because it's a rude awakening and if we
think it's bad in a country that has 300
million people what about the 3 billion
that live in the circle of India and
China well
yes but you know they may be on a slower
a their plane is behind us right there
pilot also had a heart attack but that
you know that we're maybe we're maybe
you know depending on the country were
work I mean we're living in the bleeding
edge right yeah that's why I mean I'm
sure if you plotted it out and and and
I've read this but I'm sure if you
plotted out the number of psychotic
episodes that lead to mass killings is
on the rise in the United States yeah
for sure yeah I mean anecdotally for
sure I've seen some stats on it
certainly the number of deaths is on the
rise I mean there's some argument maybe
it wasn't as well reported a few years
back but it by all metrics that I can
observe they seem to be on the rise
which is a natural aspect of our new
cycle now whoa right and and by the way
you're seeing other evidence in other
ways of like sort of mental breakdowns
where cops are shooting suspects or
whatever they and and all this is just
because we're getting closer and closer
to the landing strip without a captain
and we're gonna crash and as I said when
we crash and like so you imagine what
what causes someone this type of
psychotic episode allora it was part of
that social fabric that we were talking
about earlier especially the social
media stuff that's going on it's not
helping right for sure they're getting
they're almost being you know
radicalized by social media to your
point for sure but even leaving that
aside so these type of psychotic
episodes are almost always due to stress
like extreme levels of stress where
you're just like ah now an extreme level
of stress is highly very
and on the person so I I can handle
stress like you can't believe it can
come from things like not having food
but it can also come from things like
not being actualized yeah and that seems
to be one that's coming up quite a bit
as this heart attack has happened in the
planes crashing is there are people that
are not actualized on the plane so
there's no strong incentive for people
to try and figure it out at this time oh
yeah they don't even know the planes
crashing there in the back can I get
another drink you're like sure it's like
the captain's dead and everyone's
drinking on the plane literally that's
what that that's what's happened now the
problem is someone looks out the windows
like we're we're crashing and they're
like and then that person goes nuts and
shooting people right and so what's
happening right now is that we're seeing
you can look at it like the early
warning signs of what it what it will
look like right so if if someone and
these are the weakest members of society
who already have some history of mental
illness in many case and all the stress
of the world gets them they break they
imagine now the stress of the world gets
so great it's gonna be 50% of the but I
mean everyone has a breaking point
everyone 100% of humanity has a breaking
point yeah that breaking point is not
pretty it's drug abuse violence you
don't care anymore you're just like bam
bam and then shoot me I don't care right
and and so and I'm not trying to fear
monger here at all quite the opposite
but I think we as humanity need to to
say okay look us is way ahead of
everyone else okay way ahead we're
leading the pack on this stuff and we're
seeing losest olanta right and we're
seeing now people on the fringe of
society at a high volume going crazy and
just mass murdering people at like the
concerts and festivals and like this is
really you know nightclubs elementary
schools like uh everywhere
yeah and now and now now and that's like
and we're here now everyday you know
it's like getting closer we're gonna get
more and where nobody is like in the
back of the cabinet okay everyone put
down the drinks and we gotta figure out
how to land the plane and and you know
these communities are kind of doing
that's what you just did put down the
drinks let's go to the community let's
go and talk and let's go back with
action and let's go figure out what to
do quickly and efficiently to get other
people to put down their drinks for a
bit just so that we can talk and work
together on figuring out what to do
within the next ten years especially
within the next one and and and here's
the thing I'm not yeah I mean I'm not
even I don't know if we can stop it you
know it's I let me let me be clear what
I mean by that I think we have enough
time right now to stop the psychosis of
the crash happening in people grabbing
guns and killing one another I think we
can stop that for sure we have enough
time but thing what's happening on the
other side is there's an acceleration of
just like Moore's law in technology that
is happening in AI it's happening
obviously in computing power it's
happening in solar technology yeah bah
bah boppa so what's what's I don't think
there there's no there's no hit the
brake right I just don't see that
things are interestingly hitting the
brake let's see if I can add a little
bit of a positive spin I'm not being
knighted I know you're being realistic
is what you're being which I am very
aware of your realism and that's why I'm
so tuned into the realism we don't talk
about it so realistically on the show to
the tea that you're at we do talk about
it but not to the exact realism that
your are your metaphors are really
strong as well so let me see if I can
add a little bit of light to the realism
part of the realism is also things like
learning how to grow clean meat things
like that clean leather yeah so things
like that I think are actually all
interestingly enough kind of slowing
down the now they're slowing down the
acceleration of the plane crashing a
little bit they're their problems I have
I have issues in concept with clean I
mean I love me I mean we're we are we
are we are we are Court we're crazy
we're crazy our formula has been so
hacked that it's stunning so if you
think about and and and clean meat is
just like a great example of the easy
hacking of the human formula so humans
have to consume right there's nothing
inherently wrong with consuming but you
can play with your inherent need to
consume so then all of a sudden we own
time the crap we don't need yeah and
then you get in this like dopamine hit
of consumption and you know meat like
obviously we like meat right so then
like yeah because it's just hardwired
into our lizard brain that it's a has
protein minerals that we need
similarly we like sugar yeah like if you
found a sugar item in the past when we
were hunter-gatherers you know generally
it had a high amount
energy that you need it so you you liked
it more right so you know but now we
play on those things right so like we're
mass manufacturing meat because the
lizard brain likes it we're refining
sugars and - I mean you know we've got a
lot of work to do I mean that's all part
of the problem but but and and I don't I
agree that they're bright spots I'm not
saying that at all and I'm not entirely
sure there's enough bright spots and
even right spots yeah but my point was
there's it there that plane is going
down there's a command there is no
ability to to slow it right now it's
just to land it because the pace of
Technology technological change does not
seem that controllable by humanity it's
almost on its own yeah thing right its
own and and frequency that's it's a you
know it's on trajectory if you will and
and like we could you know I couldn't
even imagine what you would do right so
to stop it like how would you stop AI I
think the development of it I think a
really good way to at least to loop the
right people in would be to start saying
there needs to be a thesis and
philosophers around the programmers I
tried that it doesn't work it doesn't
work like so at the XPrize I was very
concerned about the genomics prize
because any great tool of prejudice will
be abused so and genomic sequencing is a
great tool prejudice you can be like
this baby will be X bigger faster
blanker than that baby is smarter right
right Wow who knows
yeah project
right and and who knows if it's true
that baby could fall on its head and
then have a and you know there's so many
things that can happen in the world
nature versus nurture but but you know
there is a huge genetic predisposition
that people have two outcomes and so
it's a tool of prejudice so I was like
look we can't just go willy-nilly and
rush off and say let's get genome
sequencing down really cheap so that
because the theoretical benefits to
humanity will outweigh the theoretical
prejudices and abuses to humanity and so
I tried yeah ethicists and others
involved and it's our 15 minutes timer
and it just didn't work they just you
know we tried no one listened no one
cared it's like this relentless March
I call it the unintended consequences
yeah and it's this March - the
unintended consequences everyone knows
the intended consequences right but no
one who seems to care about what the
unintended consequences are so I'm not
sure that you can you can slow it down I
don't think you can I think it's gonna
happen so the best thing that we can
hope for is to really land that plane as
comfortably and safely as possible and
then you know enter a new world that we
have consciously designed that's the
real bright spot yeah right so so either
you're gonna land the plane in Hawaii or
you're gonna crash in the Pacific Ocean
get eaten by sharks what would you like
to do yeah I'll take the sharks
lining eat them back there is a there's
also much truth and realism to this
metaphor and I think it's really
important to seep into the way that we
that we realistically observe our social
fabric and I think looking back at where
we actually came from and all the hard
work that went into where we got to
today when I think about the people that
worked their ass off to get us here I
think about the I think about them
thinking about us and I think about them
thinking about us seeing the plane and
the this is this is a good Fermi filter
it's one of those it's it's one of those
situations where civilizations have
evolved around stars and then some of
them don't get there because they don't
figure out how to work together and they
got it all they collapse yeah or the
societies collapse
I mean society collapses is the norm
right tell me a society that hasn't
collapsed there isn't one right Oh big
ones that's how we collectively learn
though unfortunately you know we do have
you know brilliant minds among us but we
all go down together and unfortunately
we don't have to go that's just a
paradigm that is is of our own construct
right so if we all see the plane is
gonna crash right or at least I mean
look I'm not we artists one I want to I
want to see if we can let's do a couple
quick things the first thing was you did
the one the one communities are you've
done well being social media would you
call that one I'm fog unplug unplug and
then this one coming up is consumption
consumption so what was a good takeaway
from the well being one we came up with
the probably the most effective way to
cure cancer and I hope that today
tomorrow I'm gonna start rolling pieces
of that plan out
make it happen via medium or what no no
someone else came up with the idea on
how to make it happen but but basically
most cancer is a victim of having
essentially stakeholders that are not
communicating so there was a whole story
the other day I believe it was on 60
minutes about this couple that raised an
insanely large amount of money twenty
five million dollars to cure their kids
cancer and what you end up having is
you've got stakeholders without aligned
incentives so you've got doctors that
need cures researchers that need grant
money patients oftentimes with parents
and loves ones that are supporting them
parents and loved ones don't know where
to give the money to so they're like
they're almost like silos that are you
talking about a patreon for cancer I'm
talking GoFundMe for cancer I'm talking
about it we believe the first
manifestation of which will be an event
that brings together all of the
different stakeholders and you would
think oh yeah that must happen it
doesn't the doctors with the researchers
with the family with doesn't happen it's
never bringing them together yes and
it's stupidly easy but like it kills a
conference it might be more it could be
a fundraiser potentials or fundraisers
right because the the parents and
families of cancer victims have
incredible fundraising power you know we
might look to start it with young cancer
patients who have a very high return
rate of the disease it's about two years
and it usually comes back so families
get this moment of lapse and in stress
and if they know that it's likely to
come back they can they
group together raise capital and are
highly motivated and an invaluable
stakeholder group to the problem that is
completely unleveraged by the
circumstances so so you know that I
think and and there are other people who
believe that this unifying the different
stakeholders is the way to go
so this isn't an original idea but I
think executing on it executing on it
right okay so that was the big takeaway
from well-being and then what about
unplug we we have to you know we have to
was just on Harris there or the time
we'll spend group were they there we had
we had one of the founders of modern day
social media there just by happenstance
it was we have to essentially the
takeaway was technology has stopped
connecting people and so we need to get
back to the roots and find out ways to
create innovations that actually build
meaningful connections between people
versus these superficial vanity metrics
yeah and then you know out of that
almost immediately after that like I and
some others started rallying against
social media as confluence or whatever
and shortly after that you know Facebook
Cambridge analytical stuff got leaked
and all this other stuff and so I'm not
entirely sure the cause in effect there
but you know it was certainly timely
this this gathering and then sort of the
the almost immediate downfall of
Facebook yeah thereafter yeah but but
and and who knows what will happen but
I've certainly taken that second message
on the road into heart because
we've broken I mean social media is a is
a plague right now well but out of that
takeaway that you had to build one
that's a meaningful or two to give to
connections back to get these strong
human connections back what was the
action item like how was it be how was
it built so for I think for a couple key
action items came out of it for me
number one is aligning your mind body
and soul so to speak and as as hardier
said than done you have an essence you
have a mind and you have a body and you
want to aim those things in the same
rough direction right and when you do
amazing things can happen yeah then
that's sort of a personal take away from
it but then the the broader sort of
market take away from it is that we need
to inspire the net there's no fixing
Facebook there's no fixing Twitter they
were broken from the Genesis right and
and and this goes back to you know some
thinking on AI and other things that we
were talking about there's this cut this
concept called the seed and if the seed
of an AI is good there's a belief that
the AI may be good if the seed of the AI
is bad there's a belief that the AI may
be bad well I can tell you that's
definitely true in company so you know
you think that if we paid a five or ten
bucks a month for Facebook and didn't
see ads that though it would be a better
platform no the seed is bad okay mark
built it to creep on girls at Harvard
and and it's that the fact that it's
creepy and spies on you and does devious
things is that the core of how it was
created right so to think that it can
get away from that no matter how many
years later it is is on
so it needs to be New Genesis a new seed
ok neat well so so so so to take away
from that for me I help entrepreneurs
seven days a week
yep launch new businesses and I'll be
helping tonight again ok well I'll see
you then and so my vision is to help as
many people work on meaningful problems
with the good seed as humanly possible
to make it happen that the next
generation of companies when they get
big yes will be beautiful
I like how one of the first things that
you do with your entrepreneurs that are
coming through fi is that you help them
make sure that the seed that the genesis
of that is your as best we can yeah best
we can it's not easy what and what about
hit us with the new one this new one
that's coming up on consumption what are
some of the things that you're thinking
about introducing to that well so
they're it's very experiential so you're
gonna hike through the California coast
lands eight distinct habitats from
redwoods etc down across a river into
this beautiful backcountry campsite
you'll be greeted by a Zen monk and you
bring an offering of something we should
consume less of you sort of place that
down and we go through sort of a
ceremony that I experienced as a child I
think is really nice this is a soup
drinking ceremony and then essentially
we're gonna form and some guided
meditation then we're gonna form groups
around the things that you brought and
to discuss ways to grace the consumption
and there's going to be a meal that
everything is completely raw vegan
obviously and then having metal utensils
are ceramic so there's no nothing it's
it's
done in black seed cone black seed coat
so a hundred percent of everything can
be digested or degradable if you don't
eat it yeah yeah or yeah or eaten by
something house yeah
so the you're actually gonna have a meal
with a with a you know as close to
possible a zero-waste footprint as long
as of course though those raw materials
didn't come in plastic bags themselves
and cans and stuff so like there's
always yeah I mean listen I'm with you
that so where I'm going good at though
is that it's not that so what and and
and people are gonna come back pack some
of them people are gonna come back pack
camping and by the way with the walk
through the eight coastal environments
you pass farmland that's a make some of
the most beautiful farmland you've ever
seen but you also passed some areas
where some of the farmhands live on one
of the two routes because it's a loop
and it's it's it's like a profound view
of consumption right and so so we want
to make it one part experiential right
where you're you're thinking about it
because you're being forced to think
about it because you're carrying your
own stuff because you're going out
because you're passing where food is
grown and then one part really cognitive
where you're actually participating as a
human being thinking about things
consciously consciously concrete right
and the and creatively and so you like
that combination of experiential
unconscious and and we did that in the
last one and the unplug we did it a
ranch cellphones in work mmm-hmm right
and you know you were unplugged you were
put there was no plugging in exactly yes
so you know and and then we you know did
very like deliberate get away from and
and we brought a DLS DLSR you know yeah
okay to take I'm like you know you know
what they're called anymore it's been so
long to take photos because we didn't
want people with their phones yeah
good exactly so there's a photographer
that would come with rather than you oh
no no we just brought that I don't so
there's other rules there are no two
classes there's no two classes no two
classes so there's no like you're this
and I'm that yeah no classes yeah yeah
no classes at all no two classes for
sure yeah so that's super hard to do
because essentially like I cooked a meal
for 30 people and the at the ranch it's
fun someone else may be cleaned and
someone else may be helped with a
different part of it it's a community
thing and a day I'm really happy that
you're doing this is there is there a
domain for it for people to go check it
out yeah no it's totally got it got it
and the way to hear about is to tweet at
you if they want to participate in it
and once a month this sounds awesome
yeah II we can help grow the movement
really hopefully we can grow that
movement well I hope that that everyone
here more than that the plane is coming
down yeah the metaphor is really good
and we've got it we got it we got it you
know put the alcohol away you know get
together and start talking about what
we're gonna do to land the plane and
excuse me flight attendant may I have
some LSD all right well you know I'll
tell you waking up you don't need the
psychoactive substance there's lots of
ways to do it yeah you know if you want
a shortcut fast I mean I'll tell you
you'll fast thing yeah you have physical
asleep Ness and and menthol sleepness
right and they're usually in alignment
so if you can jolt one awake it
certainly will help with the other but
there's like that moment when you're on
YouTube and you see the cat video and
then you see a really smart person
giving a talk of some sort and you just
like if you pick the smart person
can you actually lit tune in and listen
to it you'll feel much differently just
like you were describing with fasting if
you actually put your body to the test
you will feel differently you'll also
feel a sense of conscientiousness you
set yourself a goal and you follow
through with it and it feels great and
then if you keep doing that over and
over again you'll see that your life
fulfillment will slowly get better and
better and you look at the Tate you
gravitate people around you that are
like that as well okay one quick one
quick one before you I know what what is
the deepest emotion you've ever felt
acceptance
yeah
so it's hard to accept things for many
reasons so if if you can get there which
is hard it's it's very powerful but both
when we look put the mirror up and look
and accept there's maybe something that
we want to work on and get there but
also the you know he seeing that
somebody else accepts you for your for
your vision or for whatever you impact
you're trying to make and they and they
really enjoy that about you or accepting
the world and accepting the world but
also accepting the plane and that we
need more light on this plane to land it
okay alright so this has been amazing
number 66 with a day over SC I'm glad we
had you back let's see if we can do 101
32 with you as well this is uh this is
great every single time I feel like
we're we're slowly but surely unpacking
civilization ways that we can design it
to be better and it's always a pleasure
a day off we have more specific on
another one okay awesome thank you so
much guys thanks for tuning in if you
had a good time give us a share
seriously this content is really
important to get out to the world so
give it a share with people around you
give us a like give us a comment below
with your thoughts hit that subscribe
button join the community and make sure
to join us on patreon we're trying to be
sustainable we're trying to expand
trying to grill the content base trying
to inspire other creatives to do more
big events so join us there and thank
you Ron Vargas are producing partner and
thank you everyone for tuning in we'll
catch you guys soon bye guys
[Music]
[Music]
you
you